NOW, THAT'S WHAT I CALL FUNNY.
THAT'S THE "ANGLE."
JOINING US FOR REACTION IS BEST
SELLING AUTHOR COULTER AND IN
NEW YORK, CATHY A PUBLISHER.
TWO SMART WOMEN ON THIS SHOW.
CATHY, I AM SURE YOU DISAGREE
WITH SOME OF THE THINGS I SAID.
>> NOT A WORD.
YOU SAID IT'S USUALLY A LOVE
FEST.
THIS YEAR IT WASN'T.
IT WAS BEYOND THE LIP SERVICE
AND THE PATH ON THE BACK.
AND HOLLYWOOD GOT REAL.
THEY WERE AS REAL AS WHAT WAS
HAPPENING OUTSIDE OF.
FOR 90 YEARS THEY LEFT
EVERYTHING UNCOMFORTABLE ON THE
OUTSIDE OF THE THEATER.
THIS YEAR THEY BROUGHT IT IN.
IF A LITTLE BIT OF AMERICA WAS
UNCOMFORTABLE, SO BE IT.
THAT'S THE WAY MOVEMENTS START
AND HOW THINGS CHANGE.
I CONSIDER IT PROGRESS.
GOOD FOR HOLLYWOOD.
THEY GOT REAL.
>> Laura: IT'S THE ALL TIME LOW
IN VIEWERSHIP FOR THE OSCARS.
DO WE WATCH FILMS AND OSCARS FOR
THEM TO OPINE ON POLITICS?
THERE ARE REALLY SMART PEOPLE
OUT.
THERE I THINK MOST PEOPLE WANT A
RELIEF FROM THE NASTY
LEFT-RIGHT.
THEY WANT TO ESCAPE SOME OF IT.
WHEN THESE ACTORS AND
CELEBRITIES JUST MARINATE
THEMSELVES IN POLITICS, YOU CAN
WATCH US OR OTHER NETWORKS FOR
THAT.
ANN, I KNOW YOU WERE GLUED TO
YOUR TV SET.
I DIDN'T WATCH ONE SECOND OF THE
OSCAR.
I HAVE A KID WITH THE FLU AND
WENT TO BED EARLY.
>> FANTASTIC.
WE HAVE THE PERFECT PANEL TO
DISCUSS THE OSCARS.
I DIDN'T KNOW THEY WERE ON AND
DIDN'T WATCH THEM.
I HAD A FRIEND FROM THE CITY
CALLING EVERY HALF-HOUR TO GIVE
ME POLITICAL UPDATES.
I LOOKED UP VIDEOS LATER.
I AM AN EXPERT NOW.
ONE THING THAT WAS FUNNY, THIS
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE BIG ME TO
OSCARS.
IT WENT OFF THE RAILS.
ALL OF THESE WOMEN WHO WERE
RAPED AND PAWED AND HAD THEIR
CAREERS DESTROYED LIKE MIRA,
THAT WAS PUSHED ASIDE FOR
INTER-SEXUALITY.
YOU ARE GIVING MOST CELEBRITIES
FANTASTIC ADVICE.
THEY CAN TAKE IT FROM PEOPLE
LIKE US.
A FAMOUS ACTOR MADE FUN AT ME.
I SAID EVERYBODY SAYS NICE
THINGS TO YOU.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT YOUR
CHARACTER.
AT LEAST WHEN PEOPLE LOVE ME,
IT'S REALLY ME THEY LOVE.
ALL THREE OF US -- I DON'T KNOW
YOU, CATHY -- BUT YOU FOR
POLITICS.
IF YOU ARE IN POLITICS, HALF OF
THE COUNTRY WILL HATE YOU.
IF YOU ARE A SKATER LIKE SOMEONE
I USED TO LOVE LIKE LINDSEY
GRAHAM OF LINDSEY VONN, A
SKATER, SHE LOST.
WHY TAKE A POLITICAL POSITION
AND TICKING OFF THE HALF OF THE
COUNTRY?
>> THEY ARE CHOOSING TO DO SO
AND THAT'S ADMIRABLE.
THEY ARE SHOWING WE ARE
INTELLIGENCE AND NOT THE
CHARACTERS WE PLAY.
WE ARE INTELLIGENT WOMEN.
WE CAN BE DIRECTORS.
TO HAVE THE WOMEN STAND UP AND
THEY EXPLAINED EACH ROLE THAT
WOMEN PLAYED BEHIND THE CAMERAS.
MOST AMERICANS ARE NOT AWARE OF
THAT.
>> Laura: CATHY, DO YOU THINK
MOST AMERICANS CARE ABOUT THE
GENDER OR THE RACE OF THE
CINEMATOGRAPHER?
DON'T THEY CARE ABOUT WHOEVER IS
GREAT AT IT?
AREN'T WE SUPPOSED TO NOT CARE
ABOUT GENDER?
I AM CONFUSED.
I THOUGHT WE WERE SUPPOSED TO
GET AWAY FROM GENDER AND RACE.
EVERYONE IS THE SAME AND NOW
EVERYBODY IS NOT THE SAME.
WE HAVE TO BE BEAN COUNT IN
EVERY PROFESSION.
HEAVEN FORBID IF YOU ARE A WHITE
MALE.
YOU MUST HAVE SCREWED SOMEONE
OVER TO GET YOUR JOB.
SORRY TO BE HARSH.
A WHITE MALE IN HOLLYWOOD YOU
HAVE A TARGET ON YOUR BACK.
GIVEN THE ATMOSPHERE WHICH
DOESN'T GIVE DUE PROCESS TO
PEOPLE.
POOR RYAN SEACREST.
HE WAS THE PERSONA NON-GRATTAN
AFTER HE WAS CLEARED.
>> THAT'S HOW MOVEMENTS START.
THIS IS A NEW TIME.
THE NEXT 90 YEARS WE WILL CARE
MORE ABOUT GENDER.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND.
>> THEY ARE TELLING US WE HAVE
TO CARE.
>> Laura: HOLD ON.
I WANT TO PLAY ONE SOUND BITE I
THINK THAT IS POSITIVE.
GARY OLDHAM WHO WON FOR "THE
DARKEST HOUR," THIS IS WHAT HE
SAID.
>> I OWE THIS AND SO MUCH MORE
TO SO MANY.
I HAVE LIVED IN AMERICA FOR THE
LONGEST TIME.
I AM DEEPLY GRATEFUL TO HER FOR
THE LOVES AND FRIENDSHIPS I HAVE
MADE AND THE MANY WONDERFUL
GIFTS IT HAS GIVEN ME.
MY HOME, MY LIVELIHOOD, MY
FAMILY AND NOW OSCAR.
>> Laura: AND HE WAS TRASHED ON
SOCIAL MEDIA BECAUSE PAST
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST HIM.
YOU SEE ALL OF THESE PEOPLE
SITTING IN THE AUDIENCE WHO NEW
HARVEY WEINSTEIN WAS AN ABUSER
AND KNEW HE WAS ACCUSED AND
SITTING THERE BECAUSE THEY HAVE
A RIBBON ON OR GAVE A SPEECH,
THE 2 OR 3 DECADES HARVEY
WEINSTEIN DESTROYED PEOPLE'S
LIVES IS WARD AWAY.
>> I DON'T WANT TO MOVE ON FROM
THIS POINT.
THIS IS THE YEAR OF ME TOO.
A LOT OF VERY IMPORTANT PEOPLE.
SOME CERTAIN HEROES LIKE BRAD
PITT WHO STOOD UP TO WEINSTEIN
ON BEHALF OF PALTROW.
AND SORVEINO HAD HERE CAREER
DESTROYED.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A LOVELY
ACCEPTANCE SPEECH.
I CONTRAST IT WITH DEL TORO'S
TALKING ABOUT HAVING A
BORDERLESS WORLD.
HE DIDN'T MENTION THAT THE
REASON HE DIDN'T GO BACK TO
MEXICO FOR 15 YEARS BECAUSE HIS
FATHER WAS KIDNAPPED AND HELD
FOR RANSOM.
HE BETTER HOPE THAT WALL GETS
BUILT.
HE WON'T GO BACK TO MEXICO NOW.
MOVED HIS WHOLE FAMILY HERE.
TRUTH IN ADVERTISING.
>> Laura: WE ARE OUT OF TIME.